how to follow up with leads so I got a
great question for my YouTube viewers
Neal Neal's written in a few times and
some great questions this one is talking
about how to follow up with leaks and so
Neil wrote in and he said great video
Evan here's my next question how do you
hang a client who says he's moving
forward with you however after days
weeks past they just don't sign so my
view on following up with leads may be a
little different than most people I'm
gonna give you an alternative
perspective
I don't follow up with clients I don't
follow with prospects and leads I hate
it when companies keep calling on me and
they saying I haven't be ready to buy
anything you're ready to buy it this is
a great deal for you I hate that so why
would I be that person you know do you
like it when companies keep following up
and follow up with you and if you don't
then why would you want to do that to
your prospects to me it just doesn't
make sense I've also found that the
companies that you have to keep
following up with and keep pestering
they don't become great clients you know
even if they do sign with you they're
not going to be your long-term ideal
clients I'd rather not spend a lot of
time with them so here's my three-step
strategy for for following up with
clients okay and prospects number one is
make a lot of noise this is by far my
favorite strategy you should be known as
an expert in your field you should be a
known quantity in your field you're
great at what you do and people should
recognize that what I would love to have
happen is instead of you having to
follow up with a prospect they see that
you've done this interview or you can
feature it in this article or you just
wrote this great blog post and they see
your name everywhere and so that every
time they see your name that triggers
and say hey I've got a man we've got to
get needle on board this guy is really
an expert and I don't care about you get
a national exposure okay that's great
but within your field you should be an
expert in a known quantity you need to
make a lot of noise in your industry and
that comes from writing great blog posts
creating great content making great
YouTube videos doing interviews being
featured in magazines being an on-air
personality all of these things help you
have to make noise in your industry and
be the expert the more people see your
name repeatedly the more they're going
to want to
call you and say hey let's do some
business together okay number two show
public appreciation think about the
people who you like working with or who
are doing a great job helping your
audience your customers and recognize
them publicly so one of the things that
I'll do is I have a small business
champion of the day that I recognize on
Twitter and these are people who who I
think are doing a great job helping out
entrepreneurs and some of them are our
TV personalities like the people on the
sharks tank some of them are companies
who I think are often a lot of value to
entrepreneurs and I just recognize them
on Twitter and this goes out to my
entire Twitter list and it also copies
them and it's a great way just to stay
top of mind and I'm not I'm not I'm not
following up with people but I'm
recognizing them and saying hey this
company is doing a great job and it
encourages people to check them out it
keeps my name top of mind with them the
other thing you can do is create a blog
post or make a video talking about that
business and how much you like them and
what they're doing and again that's
something you can easily share with them
and just as a way to stay top of mind
now this has to be genuine you know you
have to actually like the company that
you're talking about and think that
they're doing a great job with something
somehow I'm not going to get on and do a
video about a company that I think is
crap and say hey this company is amazing
go check them out because then I lose
credibility with you and it just doesn't
feel good it doesn't feel good to do
something that isn't genuine so that's
number two and then number three my last
tip for following following up following
up with with prospects is add value add
value think about ways that you can stay
top of mind with your prospects by
adding value to the relationship
hopefully these are companies that you
care about okay and I only do this for
companies who I care about who I want to
see them be successful I think they're
doing something important and whether it
involves me or not I want to see them be
successful so here's an example of
something I've done companies often hire
me to do Twitter chats and this is where
I will go on Twitter and start talking
on a certain topic with
audience and maybe something like
finding your passion and the brand that
hires me wants to get involved and be
seen as a friend of entrepreneurs and
having helped sponsor this Twitter chat
so I've done a lot of this with
different companies and one company had
this really sophisticated tracking tool
that measured all of the tweets and how
many tweets everybody was putting out
and our total numbers and whether they
were positive or negative and the
amplification all these stats about the
tweets that were coming out and then
while this is really cool I've never
seen this before and so what did I do I
found the name of the software and I
shared it with my other clients and
prospects and said hey I was working
with XYZ company and they were using
this really really cool tool you might
want to check it out for the next
Twitter chat you have to get some better
data and analytics on it and so these
are people who have already done some
Twitter work worth before some who we've
talked about it but I haven't done
anything with it before and I guess it's
a way of following up with a prospect
but it's really more just giving them
value like I want to see them be
successful I'm keeping my name top of
mind but it's more the intention of
helping out this person giving them a
lot of value and when they're ready to
make a decision if they want to move
forward with it they're gonna come to me
because I've given them a lot of value
and I'm also showing off hey I'm doing
these projects with other companies so
those are my three reasons my three
methods to follow up with clients but
again by far my number one most
important one is make a lot of noise in
your industry you need to be that expert
and a known quantity it's a good luck
Neal thank you for the great question
for everybody watching keep believing
that you like this video give it a
thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment below you have a question leave
it in the comment section underneath
I'll make a video response just like
this one and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much and I'll see you soon
you